The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right,
so now today, the topic
we are going to discuss will
be the ON and OFF channels
in the retina.
I will provide you
with a brief overview
again of what we have
covered before about this,
and then will go on and
look at this in some depth.
Now before I start
on that, let me just
very briefly mention again
that the syllabus-- which
all of you I presume have.
If any of you doesn't have
a syllabus-- any one of you
doesn't have a syllabus,
we can provide one for you.
What I would like to
encourage all of your
again is that you do this
so-called preparatory
reading that appears
for each session, which
will make it easier
for you to follow,
and consequently, also
memorize the basic facts
that we are going
to be dealing with.
Alright, so therefore let me get
started with the so-called ON
and OFF channels.
And what I would like
to do first of all
is to tell you what are the
major questions we are going
to pose in dealing with
this very-- to me at least--
very interesting question
of the ON and OFF channels.
The first prime question
you're going to ask
is why did the ON and
OFF channels evolve?
What is their function?
As I've already
indicated before,
it is rather complicated to
have created these two channels,
and therefore there
must have been
a great deal of evolutionary
pressures to accomplish this.
So that's the prime
question we're going to ask.
Now more specifically
we're going
to ask how the
rods and the cones
are involved in the creation
of the ON and OFF channels.
And then you're going to
ask how do the ON and OFF
channels contribute
to the center
and surround organization
of retinal ganglion cells,
because this has been a big
issue among many investigators
over the past 20 or so years.
Then you're going to ask what
role do these channels play
in giving rise to the
transforms that we had discussed
the last time in visual cortex.
And lastly we're
going to ask what
are the consequences of
blocking the ON channel
on neuronal activity
and on perception.
And this last
question then will be
successful in answering
several of the questions
that we pose as to why we have
these curious arrangement of ON
and OFF channels in the retina.
All right.
So now let me first of all talk
about the neuronal responses--
sorry-- of the ON and OFF
retinal ganglion cells.
First of all, if you
remember, I told you
that back in the 19th
century, Keffer Hartline
was the first to record
from single neurons
by dissecting single
fires in the optic nerve.
And then what he did-- he
shone light into the eye.
And then subsequently--
especially when
I talked the last time
about Hubel and Wiesel--
what was done is to
use reflected light.
And most currently we
using reflected light
by presenting images on
a computer monitor facing
the animal or the
human we are studying.
Now when Keffer
Hartline did this
by shining light
into the eye, he
noticed that there are some
says which are called ON cells,
some cells that are OFF
cells, and some cells which
are both ON and OFF.
Now his idea at that time
was, using that method,
that ON cells discharge
when a stimulus came on
in the visual
field, and OFF cells
signaled their termination.
That was his idea,
and that's why
I call them ON and OFF cells.
So subsequently, especially when
reflected the light was used,
a different view had
emerged as to what
might be the reason for
having these kinds of cells.
And this was further enhanced
by the beautiful findings
of Kuffler, when he
noticed that there
was center-surround
organization in these cells
at the so-called ON,
OFF, and ON/OFF cells
responded vigorously
when a light was
shown into the center,
but responded less
when the light shown
into the surround.
So then people began to do
all kinds of experiments
to try to study this in
further detail, and one of them
was to use reflected light,
either by using a projector
or by using a color monitor.
And when they did that-- I'm
going to show this to you
schematically-- they
found that if you
had a certain lit background
like we have here,
you could present the
stimulus either by virtue
of light increment or by
virtue of light decrement.
And as I had mentioned
to you before,
the visual system
is dramatically
different from the other
senses that we have in
that we need to be able to see
dark stimuli in a background,
like letters on a page, as well
as light incremental stimuli.
And so this idea then,
if it's selected that way
schematically, looks like this.
An ON cell will fire
vigorously when a bright spot
appears in the center, and
will not fire to a dark spot.
If anything, it'll be
slightly inhibited.
OK?
By contrast, when you look at
an OFF cell, you get inverse.
It fires vigorously.
If you would, it gets
excited by a dark spot.
It gets excited by the
detriment in light illumination.
Now if you did the same thing
using a much larger spot
of light-- that is shown
here-- what you see here
is that the
center-surround antagonism
that we talked
about fully applies
to this kind of stimulation
conditions as well.
Use a large spot, bright
spot, or dark spot
and you see that
the over responses
of the cells-- the responses
are much more limited than when
you confine the simulation
to the center, only
further emphasizing
this important fact
about center-surround
antagonism--
this incredible increasing
complexity of the organization
of neurons that you see
already in the retina.
OK, so now we are
going to next look
at the anatomy of the ON
and OFF ganglion cells.
And as we look at these various
ways of studying the ON and OFF
channels, we are gradually
going to understand
what these two systems
are really for.
So the first thing is to use
this method that I had also
already described, namely that
you can record intracellularly
from a cell, understand
its functional responses,
and then you can inject
a label, and then
you can process
that anatomically
to see what it looks like.
So when this was done, a
very interesting new finding
had emerged, which
is depicted here.
Here we have the
photoreceptors--
just the tail end of
them, if you will-- that
connect to the bipolar cells.
Two bipolar cells are shown.
And then they project into the
inner plexiform layer, which
we often just refer
to as IPL, which
is subdivided into
two parts-- A and B.
And it was shown that
the majority of cells
arborize in either one or the
other of these two sublamina
in the inner plexiform layer.
But there were also some
cells, which is not shown here,
that had arborization
in both of these lamina,
and that's to
anticipate actually
the property of those cells,
which are called the ON/OFF
cells.
Now furthermore, it was found--
because these cells were
labeled after recording--
that the cells that arborized
in subliminal A, or the
inner plexiform layer,
were so-called OFF cells,
and those that arborized
in subliminal B,
like this one here,
and this one here, and this
one here, were ON cells.
OK?
So there was a distinct
spatial segregation
into the lamina of those
retinal ganglion cells that
were ON and OFF, and
also furthermore,
those that were
ON/OFF because they
had arborization
in both of them.
So that was the basic finding.
Now when that was
discovered, people
went on and asked
the question, what
is the spacial
arrangement of these cells
on the retinal
surface, if you will.
And so experiments were done
in which cells were labeled,
in most cases with
the Golgi stain,
and then the retina was looked
at head on with a microscope.
Now the interesting thing
about a microscope is,
which all of you
I'm sure know, is
that the higher
the magnification
that you use, the shorter
the focus of the microscope.
And in fact, what
you can do here
is when you look
at his head I like
that, if you can focus either
in sublamina A or sublamina B,
and if you do that, since
we had gotten these results,
you know that whatever focuses
into sublamina A would be OFF
cells, and whatever
comes into focus
and the [INAUDIBLE] is
coming to focus in B,
would be the ON cells.
So then what was
done by a fellow
called Heinz Wesley is
he asked a question, what
is the spacial
arrangement of these two?
Do they respect
each other, or what?
And so when he did that,
here is a good example
of what that looks like.
Here we have labeled both the
ON and OFF cells using the two
depth of [INAUDIBLE],
and you can
see they're kind
of helter skelter.
Then if he focus deeper, he
focus only in the ON cells.
It looks like a they're
very, very nicely arranged,
and that's also true
for the OFF cells.
And they respect each other.
Looking at the dendritic
arbors, there's
a little overlap among
the dendrites themselves
of the cells.
So what's this then said is that
the ON cells respect each other
but don't seem to give a
damn about the OFF cells.
And the reverse applied
to the OFF cells.
OK?
So as if there were two
independent entities.
So that was a very
interesting finding.
And so that was one of
the initial cues saying
that these ON and OFF
cells do different things,
and each is a devoted
entity to what it does.
All right so now to understand
this even better, let's go back
and take a brief overview
of the retinal connections
so we can understand how
these systems came about.
And the first thing to do is
to talk about the photoreceptor
basics.
And I told you many times--
by now I'm sure all of you
know that already-- that all
photoreceptors hyperpolarize
to light.
Then I also told you when
photoreceptors depolarize--
that's when they release
their neurotransmitter, which
is glutamate.
And that glutamate acts on
both the horizontal cells
and the bipolar cells.
And then furthermore, just
to look in the details--
this you don't need to remember
exactly in these words-- photon
absorption by the photopigment
results in isomerization
of the chromophore from
11-cis to all-trans.
To all-trans this causes
hyperpolarization, thereby
reducing
neurotransmitter release.
But what you do need to
remember is the next step,
which says the same thing
in much simpler words.
It says that the two
classes of bipolars,
the ON and the OFF, synaptic
junction of the OFF bipolars
is sign conserving, and
that of the ON bipolars
is sign inverting.
And so as I've told you the
last time, as you hyperpolarize
and depolarize
the photoreceptor,
an OFF bipolar cell does
the same thing like this,
but the ON bipolar
does the opposite, OK?
So you created a
two-ended system--
a double-ended system, if you
will-- from a single-ended one
that you have in
the photoreceptors.
Now, yet another fact that
is important to remember
is that the ON bipolar
cell receptor is mGluR6.
That is a specific molecule
that exists in most animals,
only in the retina, created
anew in the course of evolution,
indicating what
considerable pressure there
had to be able to
have an ON system.
And lastly I should add here
also that the OFF bipolar
receptors are mGlueR1 and 2
and they follow, pretty much,
the way the
photoreceptors respond,
which means that
their activation leads
to the opening of channels,
causing depolarization.
And of course you all know
that-- I should restate maybe
once more-- that when neurons
in the retina that had greater
potentials, when
they depolarize,
neurotransmitters released.
When they hyperpolarize,
they do not release them.
In anything, they
stop releasing them.
OK.
So now let's look at this wiring
again in more graphic detail.
Here we have a cone.
And the fact is that
in central retina,
each cone connects with at
least two bipolar cells.
So in other words, in the
retina there are many, many more
bipolars than there
are photoreceptors,
which is amazing if you
think about the numbers.
I don't know if you
remember the numbers.
I told you there are more than
50 million cones, and maybe
150 million rods, in the retina.
So the retina is an
unbelievably complex structure
with millions and millions
and millions of cells.
All right.
So what happens then-- you
create these ON and OFF bipolar
cells.
The OFF ones, by virtue are
sign conserving synapse.
The OFF, by virtue, are
And they connect with two basic
classes of ganglion cells--
the ON and the OFF.
So the ON and OFF
signals, in large part,
then are sent
separately, especially
to the [INAUDIBLE] nucleus.
But let's not forget
that they also
have the so-called ON/OFF cells.
And many of them actually end
up projecting the colliculus,
as we'll talk about later on.
So this is a very basic wiring.
They can then add here,
as I've already said.
This is sign inverting synapse.
This is sign-conserving
sign conserving synapse.
And then we can add
the fact that we
have horizontal cells that
collect signals going sideways
on the retinal surface,
thereby creating--
hypothetically speaking, at
least-- the surround effect,
although that we will look at
in just a minute in more detail
because some people had
proposed-- many hypotheses had
emerged why we have
ON and OFF channels--
and a lot of the
hypotheses was to create
this famous
center-surround antagonism
that you see in the
retinal ganglion cells.
I'll have a model
for that in a minute.
OK, so here we have
the ON and OFF systems.
And again I want
to point out to you
that they terminate in different
sublamina, the inner plexiform
layer-- the ON in sublamina
B and the OFF in sublamina A,
whereas the ON/OFF system
looks something like this.
It has dendritic arbors.
They are ON/OFF ganglion
cell in both layers,
and connects to both the
ON and the OFF like that.
So that's how you
create these three
types of cells at the
very simple level.
Now the issue that I
just to referred to
is how is this surround
mechanism created.
One hypothesis is
that it's created
by virtue of the
horizontal cells
predominantly, as shown
in this figure, which
is pretty much what
you had seen before.
So the surround is created by
the horizontal cell network.
An alternative hypothesis
that was for a while popular
was that actually the reason
we have ON or OFF channels
is to create the surround
antagonism in retinal ganglion
cells by using this kind
of wiring arrangement.
I'm not going to go
into details about this
because to anticipate
what I'm going
to tell you is that this model
does not seem to be correct,
and that of course
is often the case.
We have many, many
different models
and then one of
our tasks is to try
to figure out which
one is correct.
And you know what
often happens is
that if three models
are correct, well
there's a fourth one you
didn't even think about.
So that sometimes
happens, and especially
when you study the brain.
All right.
So now we are going to move on.
This is, unless you had read
the preparatory material,
is something that
may puzzle you--
the effects of APB
on the responses
of neurons in the visual system.
So now I'm going to ask you guys
as to how many of you actually
know what APB is.
Oh, I see all
these hands raised.
Oh my goodness.
All right.
So nobody knows what the APB is.
That's good.
So that way you are going to
learn something brand new.
But if you get a chance and
read the preparatory material,
then it will be easier for to
remember these many, many facts
that I'm going to try to impart
on you with each lecture.
All right, so APB.
APB stands for an
artificial molecule called
2-amino-4-phosphonobutyric acid.
And to show that to you in
some detail, it is shown here--
2-amino-4-phosphonobuterate .
Butyrate-- "ate," as you
know, stands for acid.
OK?
So this molecule, as I
mentioned to you before,
was invented, if you
will, by Watkins and Evans
in England, who are
molecular biologists.
And their game, as I mentioned,
is to create new molecules--
and many of which are either
analogs or antagonists
of neurotransmitters.
Now this is a glutamate
neurotransmitter
that is discharged by many,
many cells in the brain,
including your photoreceptors.
So this is a variant of that.
Now once this molecule
was invented, or created,
I should say
perhaps, people began
to ask the question, well
what is this variant?
What can they do for us?
And that was the basic
game they all played.
You create molecule after
molecule after molecule,
and then you test them to
see whether they can tell you
something useful in
studying the brain.
And it turns out that there's--
I've mentioned before also--
most of those molecules you
can throw into the waste paper
basket.
But the few of them come out
and become very, very useful.
And this one here--
that's the reason
I'm mentioning it to
you-- this APB turned out
to be a magic bullet.
First of all-- you
should remember this--
that this a
neurotransmitter analog.
So what happens is in a
way it acts like glutamate,
but it acts really specifically
on the neurotransmitter
sites of the ON bipolar cells.
And what it does-- it
fills the receptor site,
which then makes those
neurons insensitive
to subsequent light stimulation.
All right?
So this then is a
remarkable molecule.
And consequently, people began
to do all sorts of experiments.
And it was discovered that
when this substance was applied
to the retina, indeed shining
light into the receptor
fields of cells failed
to elicit a response.
But by contrast, when
as part of dark stimulus
was present in the
receptor field,
the cells continued to fire.
So that was a basic finding,
and so a method was developed
to study this in the monkey.
And let me show you
what the method is
so you can get a
sense of what it's
like to do
experiments like this.
So the method was
to put two tubes
into the eye of an anesthetized,
paralyzed animal, through one
of which you could
infuse a substance,
and through the other which
the substance could exit.
Because if there were no exiting
and you fuse something in here,
the eye would swell
up, so to speak,
and it would kill
the cells in the eye.
So you got to circulate it.
So what you have to do also
is to take the vitreous humor
and make sure that-- you know
that's a jelly-like substance--
to make it so that it was fluid
enough to come out of this tube
here, as well.
So then you could present to
the eye either a solution that
had no effect on
anything, because you made
that solution with enough
molecular substances
similar to what's in
the vitreous already.
OK?
And then what you
could do is you
could switch over using
this same substance
and add a little bit of APB.
Now APB is a very
powerful substance
so you need only small amounts
of it to have an effect.
And then what you
did is you recorded
from either the lateral
geniculate nucleus,
in this case, or from
the optic nerve fibers,
or from the visual cortex.
And so now you have
this magic bullet,
and first, however, you want
to determine, is it true.
What has been found originally
in the mutt puppy-- is it also
true in the monkey?
If you inject this APB
into the eye of a monkey,
do you really stop the
responses of ON-center cells
to view light
visual stimulation,
light incremental stimulation.
And the answer is lucky
B-- because otherwise I
wouldn't be telling
you this, of course--
is that the answer is yes.
So here is an example
of taking a response.
These are cumulative
histograms, OK?
You've turned the light
on, and then turned it off.
And you can see here's an
ON-center cell responds
vigorously under
normal conditions.
You put APB into the eye,
the cell stops responding.
And then when the animal
recovers from this,
you wash it out, so to speak,
then the response returns.
By contrast, we
do same experiment
in an OFF-center cell,
shown on the right.
You see that the cell
continues to respond
when you put APB into the eye.
So this is indeed
a magic bullet,
which selectively
blocks the ON system,
and has no significant
effect on the OFF system.
So this then opened
the gates to study
what happens when you do
these kinds of experiments--
in this case, in
monkeys-- to determine
what might be the function
of these two systems.
And so this then enabled one
to test the various hypotheses,
which I had mentioned
to you briefly before.
The first hypothesis
you can ask,
is it true-- as that model
I've shown you the right--
that it is interaction
between the ON or OFF systems
that gives rise to the
center-surround antagonism
of cells in the retina.
That's one thing you could test.
So to assess that,
let me show you
what the experimental
procedure is.
What you do here-- here is
a receptive field of a cell.
And in this case, this cell--
the recording is taking place
in the geniculate-- and
this particular cell
is one that is color selective.
It responds best to
a small red spot.
And if you hit the surround
with a different color,
the cell is inhibited.
So the way this is
then done is you
shine the light on
the center, then
you shine the light
on the surround,
and then you're
in the OFF cycle--
you just hit the surround alone.
So this then shown to
you here over time.
Here's a center stimulation.
Turn it on.
Then you hit the surround.
Then you turn it off.
So because-- and
the center stays on,
and during the OFF cycle,
you hit the surround.
So this shows the
exact manner in which
you turn these on and off.
All right.
So now the big question is,
how do ON- and OFF-center cells
respond to this
stimulus arrangement.
So say you have an ON cell,
which would discharge to this.
Then the response
should decrease
because of the
surround inhibition.
And you'll see the
normal response.
And the question
now-- what's going
to happen if you put in the APB?
Well there are a number
of possibilities.
One is that nothing's
going to happen.
That's unlikely because
I already showed you
that APB blocks the ON
response of the center.
The other possibility
is that you
lose the center-surround
antagonism, which
would prove that the ON and OFF
systems play a significant role
in creating
center-surround antagonism.
All right.
So those are some of
the possibilities.
And of course a
third possibility
is that the OFF cells also
lose their surround antagonism,
although their responses to
the center are unaffected.
So let's take a look at that.
And here are the data
under normal conditions.
This again is the stimulation
arrangement lined up,
but you can see here
there's a huge response when
you hit the center
with a red spot,
and then when you hit
the surround there's
a huge inhibition.
When you remove that,
the response returns.
And then during the
OFF cycle, there's
some spontaneous activity, but
the surround activation even
stops that.
So there's very strong
center-surround antagonism.
All right.
So now I want you to
guess for a minute.
What do you think
is going to happen
when we inject APB into the eye?
Think about it for a
minute and I'll tell you.
I listed some of
the alternatives,
and you can have a
hypothesis of your own
of what you think might happen.
All right let me show you
what really happened, OK?
When this happened, actually,
the experimenter thought,
my god, we lost a cell
while we were recording.
But then, subsequently when
the APB was washed out,
you got the same
response as before.
And so the cell wasn't lost,
but the APB was so effective
that it stopped the
response of the cell
completely, both of the
center and to the surround.
And now let's ask the question,
what happens when you do this,
not to an ON-center cell,
but an OFF-center cell.
Think about it
again for a minute
and ask what do you
think would happen then.
OK, so here it is.
Here is an OFF-center
ganglion cell.
And it shows here, using the
same stimulus conditions, that
in this case, because
there's an OFF
cell, adding the
surround decreases
the degree of inhibition
turning OFF cycle.
And here again the same
thing is happening.
But the same thing happens
under both normal conditions
and after APB had been injected.
So what this experiment then
shows-- and of course one
does this with
many, many cells--
is to prove that the
hypothesis, that the ON and OFF
systems play a significant role
in center-surround antagonism,
is wrong.
And because of that, that
hypothesis has been eliminated.
All right.
So then we can move on
and ask the next question.
I mean, let me first
draw this up again here.
All right.
Here we have the
photoreceptors--
the cone photoreceptors-- the
horizontal cells, and the ON
and OFF cells.
So this alternative hypothesis,
that the surround inhibition
is due to horizontal
cells, therefore,
has gained much
greater acceptance.
OK.
So now we are going
to move upstairs
and we're going to go to area V1
where we can ask the question,
well what were the transforms
that we had seen in V1.
I presume all of you remember.
What are the three major
transforms we talked about?
Who remembers?
Come on.
Sure you remember that, don't
you-- that we have cells--
most of the cells are
orientation specific, right?
Most of the cells are
direction selective.
And most of the
cells are selective
for spatial frequency.
So those are three of
the major transforms.
The other two we talked about is
a convergence of the ON and OFF
channels onto single
cells in the cortex.
And the other was that
there was a binocular input
to many of the cells.
So those were the
major transforms
we talked about the last time.
And again I want to emphasize
the importance of this
by telling you that
Hubel received the Nobel
Prize for those discoveries
of how V1 operates.
OK?
And of course I mentioned
before that Keffer Hartline,
when he discovered the ON
and OFF systems using light
that he shown into the eye--
he called them the ON and OFF
cells-- he received the
Nobel Prize as well.
So those are truly, truly
major, major discoveries
and have triggered hundreds
and hundreds of experiments
trying to understand better.
And certainly one of the
questions that was raised
is how does orientation,
and direction cell activity,
and special frequencies
activity, for that matter,
arise in area of V1.
And one prominent
hypotheses was indeed
that the reason we have
ON and OFF channels
is to create these transforms
in the visual cortex.
So what we can then
do, now that one
has this magic
bullet of the APB,
that one can record
from a cortical cell.
See how it responds when
you inject APB in contrast
to before you injected
it and after injected it.
So that's the big question
you're going to ask next.
All right.
So here is an example of what
of cortical cell's response
looks like using this kind of
histogram when a bar of light,
in this case, is moved
across the receptive field.
Now this is a complex cell.
And you can see it gives
a vigorous response when
the light edge goes
across, and then it
gives a vigorous response when
the dark edge goes across.
I'm showing this only for
one direction of motion.
So that is a natural response.
So now the question
comes up, what
happens when you inject
APB into the eye.
A number of possibilities exist.
The most basic one I think
most of you would buy
is that the light edge response
is produced predominantly
by the ON channel,
and the dark edge
response by the OFF channel.
And if that is the
case, then this response
should be eliminated by
blocking it with APB in the eye.
And if you do that, that's
exactly what happens.
You can see here under
normal conditions,
you get a vigorous response
for both light and dark edges.
After APB, only a dark
edge response remains.
So this then established
that these responses
to the different edges-- the
light edges and dark edges--
are a product of the input from
the retina to the geniculate,
and then to the cortex from the
ON and the OFF channels, which
then converge in
many cortical cells,
as is the case in this
particular cortical cell.
So that then establishes
this very basic fact.
Now the next
question we can ask--
what about those transforms
you talked about?
Let's first of all
look at the transform
of direction selectivity.
So we can take a cell
that is, in this case,
directionally biased.
And you can see what
the response is before
and after APB is injected.
And what you see
here-- we move the bar
across in one direction, and
then we move the bar back
across the opposite direction.
So the first half shows
a downward movement--
the second half,
the upward movement.
Now what you see here
that the cell responds
is much more vigorous.
It's not 100%
direction selective.
I showed you some of
those the last time.
This one is a bias--
about a four to one bias--
much more response to
the downward movement
than the upward movement.
But the cell responds both
the light and the dark edge
in both directions,
and it lines up
with the temporal
arrangement here,
proving indeed that
this is a complex cell.
Now then when you
inject APB into the eye,
look what happens.
You eliminate the light
edge response here and here,
but the cell is still
directionally biased.
So direction specificity
was maintained.
And when this was
studied in many,
many, many cells--
even cells that
were 100% direction specific--
blocking the ON channel
did not eliminate
directionality in the cortex.
So that then indicates that
the ON and OFF channels did not
arise to bring about direction
selectivity in the cortex.
And so that brings us
to the second transform,
which is orientation
specificity.
So we can do that next.
And here we have an example
using a very similar procedure.
Again, a complex cell
when the APB is injected.
The light edge
response disappears.
You move the bar across
the different orientations
and this is the orientation
specificity you get.
Now this is calculated here on
the basis of only the dark edge
response because you
want to keep it the same
as you're going to do here.
Since the light edge
response is eliminated,
you can see that the cells
orientation specificity is also
unaffected, meaning
that the orientation
specificity of
the cortical cells
is not due to the interaction
between the ON and OFF channel.
Similar experiments were also
done with spatial frequency
selectivity, and again,
no effect was found.
So this then led
to the conclusion
that the ON and OFF
channels did not
arise for the purpose of
creating the transforms that we
had denoted in our last
lecture about single cells
in the visual cortex.
All right.
So now what we can do
is here-- we can come up
with a silly model, just
to make it memorable,
which is to say
that the ON and OFF
channels flow into the cortex.
And these attributes we talked
about-- orientation, direction,
and spacial frequencies
selectivity--
are produced by
cortical filters.
What you have in
the cortex are all
kinds of inhibitory interneurons
and the interactions
among many, many neurons.
And that kind of
activity that you
get there is the one that
produces these attributes,
not the interaction between
the ON and OFF channels
that flow into
the visual cortex.
All right.
So now the next
question we can ask,
or what happens on APB under
photopic viewing conditions.
We'll talk about scotopic,
as well as photopic, vision.
To do this, and to answer how it
affects our visual capacities,
what we do is to turn to
behavioral experiments.
In behavioral experiments,
what you can do
is you can present
various kinds of stimuli.
You can train a
monkey-- in this case,
with monkeys-- to see how
well they perceive a stimulus,
and ask them to make an eye
movement to that stimulus.
So when you do
this-- testing that
hypothesis I've shown you
earlier about light increment
and light decrement--
what we can do
is to train a monkey
to first fixate.
And then after the
monkey fixated,
you can present either
a light incremental spot
or a light decremental spot.
The monkey's task is to make
a saccade to that target.
And of course, those
spots will appear randomly
in several different
locations in each trial,
so the monkey doesn't know
where he's going to appear.
And if he makes a
correct saccade to it,
he will get a drop of
apple juice for a reward.
So that is the procedure.
And so now the question
then comes up--
how well does the
monkey do in being
able to detect light
increment and light decrement?
So if you do that, luckily
one gets a very clear cut
and dramatic result.
Here is the section
that I will show
you data for light
increment, and here
is a section showing
data for light decrement.
So here is an example.
What you measure
here are two things--
you measure the monkey's
percent correct performance,
and you measure what the
saccadic latencies are
to make a saccade to the target.
So it shows here that
under normal conditions,
the monkey's
performances is over 90%,
and that he has a
very nice distribution
of saccadic latencies
with a mean of about two
in 53 milliseconds.
Then when you apply APB
to the eye, what happens
is that the monkey's
performance drops dramatically.
He is just a little
bit above probability,
and his latencies are very,
very late-- very, very,
very long-- 406 milliseconds.
So in other words,
the monkey can barely
perceive a light
incremental stimulus
by virtue of having blocked
the ON channel in the retina
by APB.
Now if you do the
same experiment
with light decrement,
what you see here
is the monkey's
performance remains
normal-- about 95% correct.
And the latency
distribution is also
about the same-- two in 49,
versus two in 51 milliseconds.
So that then says that
indeed the ability
to detect light
incremental stimuli
has been devastated by
the injection of APB,
and therefore raised the
idea that the ON and OFF
channels are for the purpose
of quickly and efficiently
detecting light increment,
as well as light decrement.
So that then was
the basic finding
that was obtained with this
behavioral experiment studying
the monkey's
performance on being
able to process visual stimuli.
Now we are going to get
a bit more complicated,
because what we
talked about so far
was under photopic
conditions, meaning
when your cones were
fully functional.
So the question is what happens
under scotopic conditions,
meaning what happens
when you're dark adapted.
Now we have talked
about this before.
It was pointed out,
initially by Schultze,
that we have two basic classes
of photoreceptors-- the rods
and the cones-- and that the
rods are for night vision.
So now the question is, what
happens under night vision
conditions.
And when this was found-- this
was truly, truly baffling.
And I'm going to
show you the data.
It showed here under
light adapted conditions
with the same kind of
data-- but shown only
as histograms in this
case-- the monkey
does equally well
for light and dark.
And when you apply
APB, the monkey
has difficulty seeing the
light incremental stimulus,
but has little loss in the
light decremental stimulus.
OK?
But when you do the same thing
under dark adapted conditions,
when only the rods
are operative,
a curious thing happens.
The monkey doesn't see either
light increment or light
decrement.
In other words, and the
way to put it shortly,
is to say that the monkey
has become night blind.
Now there are, among humans, a
small population of individuals
individuals who are
night blind, and what's
the situation with them?
It's called "night
blind" because they just
see very poorly at night.
And, in fact, when
that is known,
they only get a special kind
of driver's license-- one
saying you can drive
in the daytime,
but you can't drive at night.
So now we have a
monkey here with APB
injected-- that
he's night blind.
And also you see the same data
reflected in the latencies,
just like before.
And it shows that the
monkey is devastated
both for light increment
and light decrement
by having a tremendous
increase-- more
than a tripling of
latencies for the few trials
that he did carry out correctly.
So now this being the case,
it raises a big question--
and I'm sorry that things
are getting so complicated,
but the brain is
complicated-- as
to just what is the nature
and arrangement of the rods
in the retina, and
how does that relate
to the arrangement of the cones?
OK?
So that brings me to
an interesting point.
Again, as so often
happens, whenever
you're confronted
with a puzzle, you
have all kinds of hypotheses.
And then luckily if you do
this instead of experiments,
you come up with the
right kinds of tools.
You can eliminate most of them
and come up with the right one.
Now, so we can
ask, first of all,
without talking
about APB at all now,
simply ask a general
question-- what
happens to the receptive fields,
or retinal ganglion cells,
under dark adapted conditions?
And what happens is that the
receptive fields become larger.
Now this initially-- discovered
by Barlow in England--
was negated by the other
individuals saying,
you just got scattering of
light-- that's why it's larger.
So it was kind of
dismissed, but in the end
it turned that he was
right, as you shall see.
The other thing that happened
is that the color selectivity
response disappears in the
retinal ganglion cells.
And not only that, but it
disappears behaviorally.
So when you have a
red rose, and you
look at a red rose at night when
only your rods are functional,
it looks like a black rose.
The rods cannot process color.
OK?
They can only process light
increment and decrement.
OK, again just to reiterate--
the receptive fields
become larger.
OK.
So the big question is
what on earth is happening,
what kind of wiring
is taking place,
or what kind of
connections are created
to create these two things.
Now the second one is the
one that's the big puzzle.
The first one we can
understand because it's
been shown that rods
are only one type
and that they don't
carry color information.
Now to study this further, way
back when in the 1870s-- 1880s,
Cajal did the large number
of experiments of this sort.
If you remember, I told you
that Cajal played a central role
in using the Golgi stain, and
that he and Golgi received
the Nobel Prize in 1906
for their major discoveries
about this.
So now he argued that
the way this happens
is that rods and the
cones connect differently
with the ganglion cells.
And so here is a
picture of Cajal.
He spent most of
his life like this,
looking through a
microscope, endlessly looking
at brain slices, and studying
the individual cells--
the shapes and drew them,
as you can see his pencil.
He is in the middle drawing,
actually, a cell there.
And so he speculated
about this a great deal.
And he was just a
remarkable person.
And he had written
an autobiography.
And the way he speaks in this--
translated from Spanish--
but he has an incredibly
colorful way of talking--
"had," I guess I should say.
And I want to
quote some of this,
because I think you'll find
it interesting and amusing.
So he said, "Since this
impression received by the rods
is different from that
taken by the cone,
it is necessary from
every point of view
that each of these
specific impressions
should be conveyed through the
retina by a separate channel."
The translation leaves a lot
to be desired, but that's OK.
So then he went
on and said, "When
we reason with common sense
and lift a war club determined
upon vigorous action,
nature ultimately hears us."
Very picturesque, as if nature
had heard anyone, right?
"Knowing what I was
looking for--" meaning he
had a hypothetical bias, right--
"I began to explore eagerly
retina of fishes and mammals.
Finally as a reward
of my faith, there
deigned to appear most clearly
and brilliantly those two
types of bipolar cells
demanded by theory
and guessed by reason."
What he means by
this is that there
were two kinds of basic
kinds of bipolar cells--
and not the ON and OFF.
But in this case, what
he was talking about,
he was talking about rod
bipolars and cone bipolars.
He said the rod photoreceptors
connect with rod bipolars,
and the cone photoreceptors
with cone bipolars.
So that's what [INAUDIBLE]
then established,
and that finding was
basically correct.
But then he went on to say that
these two kinds of bipolars
hook up with two types
of ganglion cells,
thereby forming separate
channels to the brain.
So that was an interesting
conclusion, and for many years
that was accepted.
And interestingly enough,
as it so often happens
with hypotheses,
this conclusion--
even though you had
the drawings looking
through the microscope
showing that there were
these separate channels--
turned out to be largely
not one-- almost entirely wrong.
Now what do we mean by that?
Well people began
to do all sorts
of very careful intercellular
recordings in the retina,
and using much
more sophisticated
anatomical procedures
than Cajal was
able to use, thanks to the
new developments in the field.
And they discovered, first of
all-- let me back up a second.
This is sort of the model
that he had proposed.
He had the cone model
and the rod model,
not distinguishing
between the ON and OFF.
And so the model that
then subsequently emerged
was that ganglion cells
in most of the retina
actually receive a convergent
input- except in the fovia,
because you don't have rods
there-- so that you don't have
a doubling of ganglion
cells-- some for rods
and some for cones-- but
both the rods and the cones,
through separate pathways,
feed into the ganglion cell.
So then this was analyzed
in much, much more detail.
And now I'm going to point this
out to you by providing you
with an overview of the
retinal connections.
OK.
So here we have the three
basic classes of cones.
All right?
And we have the rods.
Then, if you look at
the cones, each cone
gives rise to at least two
bipolar cell-- an ON and OFF
bipolar cell.
But the rods in
most species only
have a single kind
of bipolar cell,
and they can refer to that
as an ON bipolar cell,
because the synapses are all
sign-inverting synapses using
the mGluR6 neurotransmitter
receptor site.
So that's what we have there.
Now if you look further down
here at the ganglion cells--
and what we have is of course,
that we have the ON and OFF
bipolar cells from
the cones feed
into the ON and
OFF ganglion cells.
So now the questions are what
happens to the ON bipolar
cells?
How do they connect
to these cells
since they do not form
a separate pathway?
And this has been
again-- things got
very complicated in
the course of evolution
where it was very important
to try to conserve things
as much as possible,
and that's why we do not
have separate pathways
for rods and cones.
If we did we'd need
a huge eye, and we'd
need at least twice
as many ganglion cells
than we have at the present
time, which is about a million
in each eye.
OK, so what really happened
is-- dumb-founding almost--
is that a so-called
amacrine cell --
I told you there are different
classes of amacrine cells--
one of them is a so-called
A2 amacrine cell.
That is a cell that
receives a direct input
from the ON bipolar cells.
Now that amacrine cell
connects to ganglion cells
in two different ways.
It makes a gap junction
connection with the ON bipolar
cells, and it makes a
glycinergic synaptic connection
with the OFF ganglion cell.
So let's label this.
What we have here-- this is
inner plexiform layer again,
and here is the outer
plexiform layer.
And what we have here--
just to remind you,
that already know-- we have
a sign-inverting synapse
for the ON, and sign-conserving
for the OFF bipolars
that connect with the cones.
And now we have here-- let's
proceed to the A2 amacrine
cell that is feeding into
these cells from the rods.
And what we have here is a
glycinergic synapse, so-called.
That's a real synapse.
It's inhibitory.
And then here we have what
is called a gap junction.
I'm sure all of you know
what these things are.
Gap junction is what you
call an electrical synapse.
So they transform the signal
without any neurotransmitters
involved.
So it directly activates-- in
this case, this fiber here--
and drives it.
So what you create
in the inner retina
then here is a
double ended system
for the rods that is created in
the outer retina for the cones.
So you create [INAUDIBLE].
Here are the OFF, and here are
the ON inputs to the ON and OFF
ganglion cells.
Now because of this
arrangement, what happens
is that the size
of the receptive
fields under dark
adaptive conditions
is bigger because a bigger range
of connections from the rods
to the ganglion cells.
So all this is nice
wiring that finally,
after many, many
years of experiments,
has been clarified.
Sorry it is so complicated.
That's just how it is.
Explains then the claim that
you have bigger receptive fields
at night than in the daytime.
And now that has been
generally accepted.
OK so now the central
conclusions that we come to
is that ON and OFF
channels have emerged
in the course of evolution
to enable organisms
to process light both
incrementally and decrementally
for being able to see
things rapidly and quickly.
All right?
So that is the prime function.
Nature has gone to
incredible extent
to modify the basic organization
of the visual system
and the retina to
create a way to be
able to process
both light increment
and decrement rapidly.
Now that may provide you
with a little cute mnemonic,
if you will.
Here we have a fish.
Fish also, believe it or not,
have ON and OFF channels.
Now what happens is
if below here there
is a predator--
a large fish that
is trying to catch this fish--
because of the sun shining
on it, it reflects
the light, and so
this fish would see
this particular predator
by virtue of light increment.
Got it?
By contrast, if you
have osprey up here
that's trying to
catch this fish,
that osprey against the sky
would be seen as a dark object.
OK?
And so now, since this fish
has both ON and OFF cells
in its retina, it's
going to do this.
You ready?
He's going to escape, OK?
So that then, in a
nutshell, tells us
why we have ON and OFF channels
in the visual system-- namely
to enable us to process both
light increment and light
decrement effectively.
And as I've mentioned
to you before,
whenever you read or
write, you see things
mostly by virtue
of your OFF system
because you have dark print or a
dark pen on a light background.
But of course the
obverse is also the case.
So this was known
for ages and ages.
And that's why
eventually, instead
of having print
in which you have
a black page with
white letters, you now
a white page with black
letters, because that's
much more economical to achieve.
And you can read both
light incremental
and light decremental
letters equally well
because we have these
ON and OFF channels.
OK.
So on the basis of
this then, we are
ready to summarize why we
have this remarkable duality
in the retina, originating
in the ON and OFF channels,
whose circuits we
by now, I presume,
you understand pretty well.
So just to reiterate for
the umpteenth time, which
is easy to remember by
now, all photoreceptors
hyperpolarize to light.
Secondly, the cone driven
ON and OFF channels
originate at the level of
the retinal bipolar cells.
OK?
For ON bipolars
you have a system,
which involves
sign-inverting synapses.
OK?
The neuron transmitted by
the way of the photoreceptors
is glutamate.
And you come to the receptor
sites-- the mGluR6 receptor is
the one that inverts the signal
for the ON bipolar cells.
And the mGluR1 and 2 is the
neurotransmitter receptor site
for the OFF bipolar cells.
Now APB-- can
important to remember
this-- is that glutamate analog.
A lot of people make a mistake
and think it's an antagonist.
It's a glutamate analog.
So what happens is that
it blocks the ON bipolar.
Now let me say just a couple
more words about this.
We move our eyes about
three times a second.
Every time you move your eye
some mechanisms in the retina
wipe the slate
clean, so to speak,
because if it didn't,
then the image that
would fall on the retina
after you moved your eye
would interfere
with the image that
had fallen on the
eye beforehand.
So there's an
incredibly rapid system
that breaks down the
molecular arrangement
of glutamate and many other
transmitters in the retina
so that with each
movement of the eye,
you can see things clearly.
Now there is an exception
to that, of course,
under extreme conditions.
We have what is
called "after images,"
like when you look at
the sun for a while.
Then you will see an after
image lingering on in your eye.
But under normal
illumination conditions,
the slate is wiped clean
with every shift in the eye.
Quite amazing.
All right.
Then APB blocks the ON response
of retinal ganglion cells.
The OFF response and
center-surround antagonism
are unaffected.
APB blocks lighted
responses in the cortex,
but has no effect on
orientation, direction,
and spatial frequency
selectivity.
APB reduces the sensitivity
for light increment,
and the ON and OFF channels for
rods arise in the inner retina.
And I should add
here that there's
only one kind of rod bipolar,
which is the ON-type.
There are no OFF-type
rod biopolars.
Then in most primates there
are only ON rod bipolars.
The rod ON and OFF
channels are created
in the inner retina
by the amacrine cells,
predominately by the
so-called A2 amacrine cell,
as I told you.
Lastly, excitatory
signals are generated
for both light increment
and for light decrement
by virtue of the ON
and OFF channels.
So those are the
major conclusions
that we need to make about this
remarkable achievement of how
the visual system works,
by virtue of having created
the ON and the OFF channels,
by virtue of having then
done this, by virtue of creating
from a single-ended system
of the photoreceptors,
a double-ended system
at the level of
the bipolar cells.
So that then is--
sorry how complicated
it is-- the basic layout of
the retina and the ON and OFF
channels.
Next time we are going to talk
about yet another subdivision
in retinal ganglion cells-- the
so-called midget and parasol
cells.
I think I've mentioned
to you before that we
have several different classes
of retinal ganglion cells--
not just ON and OFF.
And the so-called
midget and parasol cells
have ON and OFF subdivisions.
And then there are
several other cells
that do all kinds
of other things.
We will talk about
some of those.
But the overwhelming, largest
number of cells in the retina
are the midget and the
parasol, and so they
deserve the greatest
scrutiny as to why
we have those two systems.
And that's we are going
to discuss the next time.
So that pretty well finishes
what I had to cover today,
and so if any of you
have any questions,
I will be happy to try to answer
them for you, as long as it
pertains, of course, to
the ON and OFF channels.
Anybody not clear
on the rules of how
APB works-- that it's an analog,
that it fills the receptor
sites of the ON bipolar
cells, rendering
them insensitive to
subsequent light stimulation?
Now I should add maybe
one more thing here
is that unlike the glutamate,
which is broken down
in milliseconds, this
artificial substance-- APB--
there's no natural
optic mechanism for it.
And so it lingers on, and
that's why it is so effective.
And it has to be washed out
of the eye-- you typically
have to wait 10-- 15 minutes
for the eye to return to normal
because there's no rapid
optic mechanism for the APB,
in contrast to the glutamate.
Well it sounds like I
was reasonably clear.
I hope you can absorb
this and marvel
at the inventiveness, if
you will, of evolution
to have created this
incredible mechanisms that we
see in the retina.
It's just dumb-founding.
Yes, it's just incredible.
So that then is what we
going to finish with today.
And so I will see
you Wednesday, and we
talk about the midget and
parasol systems, which
is also very
interesting, by the way.
And I hope you've
enjoyed hearing
about what those
two systems are for.